from nbc new york says governor andrew
cuomo has issued the
first in the nation executive order
declaring gun violence in new york as a
disaster emergency
the first step in a comprehensive plan
that aids that aims to
tackle the surge in gun violence
throughout the state
the announcement was made at john jay
college of criminal justice in manhattan
in new york tuesday afternoon
this is the first step in a
comprehensive plan cuomo outlined
composed of seven key areas all with the
aim of quelling the gun violence surge
the key areas are quote treat gun
violence like the emergency public
health
it is um target hot spots with data and
science
what does that mean this is how we're
going to solve gun violence target it
with science
what are you going to do about gun
violence science
what do you mean that you know science
solves everything positive engagement
for at-risk youth
number four break the cycle of
escalating violence
number five get illegal guns off the
street number six keep guns out of the
hands of dangerous people seven rebuild
the
police community relationship just a
whole bunch of broad
vague you might as well say um i have
one step to solving the gun violence
problem number one solve the gun
violence problem
how do you put break the cycle of
escalating violence as one of the steps
on the way to achieve
that is the goal now how are you going
to do that
is the question oh you're just going to
you're going to declare
gun violence a public health emergency
okay that's really going to help this
this is part of the the religion of the
left they believe that
every bad thing is a public health
emergency
um because everything has to be framed
in a sort of
sanitized medical kind of way
everything becomes a health crisis it's
a it's a really a medical
scientific issue and why do they do that
because they're trying to remove the
moral dimension from all of these things
and they think just by declaring
something a public health crisis that
that
in itself will solve the problem and
in trying to remove the moral dimension
what they're looking to avoid is the
reality
that gun violence happens just like all
other kinds of violence and there's a
lot of it happening in our cities and
not all of it
involving guns but it happens because
individual human beings make the choice
to behave this way
but they don't want to talk about choice
because when you talk about choice then
you have to ask well
why are they making this choice why are
they acting this way
if you got a 17 year old guy um out
there on the street in
in in new york or chicago or baltimore
and he just goes up
and shoots someone dead to steal his
shoes
or because he's selling crack on on a
street corner where where he would
prefer to be um yeah you could blame the
gun if you want and say this is a public
health emergency
or you can ask what in the world has
happened
that would that would lead to this 17
year old
throwing someone's life away and his own
life away
for nothing this is someone who does not
value life his own or anyone else's
how do we get there that's the real
disaster emergency and i'll tell you one
of the ways that we've gotten there
you wanna you wanna talk about the real
disaster emergency quote unquote in
urban communities in the cities it's
that almost
all of the people responsible for this
quote unquote gun violence
don't have fathers in the home that's
not the only thing that's not the only
contributing factor but it's a big one
you know when you've got 70 80 percent
of fathers choosing not to be in the
home raising their own kids
yeah you're going to have a gun violence
epidemic and you're going to have a drug
abuse epidemic and you're going to have
a
suicide epidemic and you have you're
going to have crime of all kind is going
to be an epidemic
if you were to cut that if even let's
say we're at 70 in the city right now
if we were to make it 45
or let's say 40 cut it down by 30
percent
40 would still be an enormous number
but you would see magically so much of
this gun violence would disappear
but we can't discuss that that is not in
the seven key areas that he outlines
doesn't talk about that doesn't talk
about how almost
all of these perpetrators of gun
violence
don't have debts
um governor cuomo also on the the gun
violence front tweeted this as well he
said the gun industry is the only
industry in america with immunity from
civil lawsuits
it's an insult to victims of gun
violence today i'm signing legislation
to reinstate public nuisance liability
for gun manufacturers in new york state
um
i thank the sponsors of the bill well
that's just that's just a lie just so
you know when you hear this thing about
how gun manufacturers are
uh are not liable or they're they're
insulated from from
from lawsuits or anything they have
immunity from civil lawsuits
that is not true a gun manufacturer can
be sued
under the same for the same reason that
the manufacturer of any other product
can be sued
if you sell someone a product and it
malfunctions it does
something that it's not supposed to do
and somebody gets hurt or killed in the
process
you get sued for that if i take my glock
19 down to the range and i pull the
trigger and it explodes and kills me
my family could definitely sue them for
that
but what you can't do is sue someone
or sue the manufacturer of a product
if somebody else takes that product and
uses it
in in in an illegitimate and illegal
criminal way
that's what you can't sue gun
manufacturers for obviously
if there's an axe murderer running
around out there you can't sue
home depot because that's where he
bought the ax much less can you sue
the company that made the axe
you can't do that if somebody buys the
axe and they pick it up to uh cut some
wood and the
you know the blade comes flinging off of
the axe and hits someone in the head and
kills them again you could sue them for
that
but if you take the axe and choose to
use it
in a way that you're not supposed to um
then you're the one liable same for guns
so this is a misnomer this is a false
it's a lie in other words
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated